あるもの餓鬼 餓鬼道の餓鬼を見てね
木蓮尊者がね 驚いちゃって
で 誰にも言わなかったんですね
それで見た時は何かニコッと笑ったんです
それで他の人 なんで笑ったんでしょうか？って言ったら
もう聞くなよと 聞きたければお釈迦様のところで聞きなさいよと
言うとそのラッカナ長老でしたっけ
この前のエピソードも同じエピソードですからね
餓鬼の だから前のエピソードでも大丈夫ですけど
このラッカナ長老と目連尊者なんですね
目連尊者がすごい瞑想は上手ですからね
すごい超能力 天眼がありましてね
うん そしたらこの お釈迦様のところで聞きなさいよと言うんですね
それでお釈迦様がいるところで
ラッカナ長老が目連尊者なんで笑ったんですかね？霊寿泉下りる時はと
そしたら私は実はね こういう餓鬼を見たんだと
あまりにも残酷なさに笑っちゃったと
仏教は笑うんです 残酷なことを見ると
どういうことですかね
で 笑うっていうことはあんまりいい単語ではないんですけどね
すっごい体がでかい餓鬼で
血がうたっぱまねになったんか
かなり背が高い すごいでっかい体の餓鬼で
まあ幽霊だからね 別に肉体の体ではないんですけど
で 体から火が燃えてるんですね
で ６０００個のこの 叩くやつ
あの金槌 何でしたっけね
ハンマー ハンマーがあって ６０００
なんですね これが空から次から次へと落ちてくるんで
この餓鬼の体に 一つでも落ちたら体全部壊れて
ずっとハンマーが下まで落ちるんです
体通して壊れて だから痛くてものすごい泣くんです
泣いてもまたすぐ体が出来上がっちゃう
それでまた また次から次
から これも絶えずもうその苦しみを味わってますね
で まあこれは精神的な苦しみだと思いますけど
これ肉体持ってるわけじゃないんだからね
だからこの餓鬼道っていうのはあり得ることで
この人間も人間でいながら餓鬼道を作る場合ありますね
頭 妄想して妄想の世界に閉じ込まれる
それでもう餓鬼道なんです
もう抜けられなくなるんです
本人にとっては本当に苦しいんです
だからどんな妄想って
それはそれぞれ妄想次第でね
例えばもう もう細菌が自分をもう噛んで
もうもうもうずっと虫食んでいるんだとかね
なんとか妄想しちゃうと
本人には本当に自分の細胞が虫が食べて食べて食べていくような感じるんです
痛くてたまらんです 我々から見ると何のことないな
これはと ただ普通でしょうと言ったっても
本人が妄想 そういう妄想作っちゃうともう抜けられなくなるんですね
そういうことで いろんな妄想が無数にありますからね
だからどんな妄想に閉じ込められるかっていうことは片方じゃないんです
精神的に病気っていうのはそういうことなんですね
幻聴あったり 幻覚が見えたり
鬼が見えたり 自分もいろんなこと
あるいはずっと自分の後ろから誰かがもうついてきて
自分のことを調べているんだとか妄想作っちゃうと
もう誰もあなたのこと調べてないんだと言ったっても意味がないんだ
本人には実際ですからね
本物だから だから妄想ですけど
妄想から生まれる苦しみは本物なんです
[背景音楽]だから本人にとってはものすごい苦しいんです
そういう妄想ない人が助けてあげようと
どう助けてあげるんですかね
怒られますからね だから一番いいことは笑っちゃうこと
じゃあもうはい そうですね
苦しいですね まあ私たちは妄想しないんだから
本当に幸せよかったなとかね
いうふうに差別するしかないんです
だから目連尊者がニコッと笑うんで
こんな阿呆がね 自分で苦しんでるんだと
それで餓鬼道の場合は餓鬼道は餓鬼道だからね
それを変えられません
この妄想の幻覚の境地に陥るんだから
生まれ変わるんだからね
これはもう変えることできませんよ
我々は例えばこの肉体を持って生まれたんだから
水の中で生活できませんだからね
これはどうしようもないんです
一旦生まれた境地の範囲の中で生活しなくちゃいけないんです
餓鬼道の場合は そういう妄想の次元なんですね
だから一旦落ちたら寿命はわからないんですよ
妄想はいくらでも続くんだから
だからすごく寿命も長いし
やがて妄想で苦しんで苦しんで苦しんでもう飽きちゃったところでゆっくりと治りますけどね
で 業になりますから 餓鬼はもう救い
もう難しい 生まれてからその業が終わるまで
その幻覚の苦しみで苦しまなくちゃいけない
例えば実際包丁に刺されるとすごく危なくて怖くて
怯え 怯えますよ それは実際に包丁刺されたんだからね
これは一回しか刺されません
それからさっさと病院に運んでもらって
長い時間すごい痛みを感じながら治療して
なんとか治してもらいます
傷痕残るかもしれませんだけど
いろいろ後遺症みたいなものも残るかもしれませんけど
治りますね しかし そういう妄想だったら
大変です そういう妄想があって
幻覚が起きたと 自分が包丁で刺されたんだと
それで苦しみは同じなんです
恐怖感も同じなんです
自分が刺されるんだから
逃げよう逃げようとしてるんですけど
逃げられない 幻覚だからやっぱり刺されます
しかし 実際は傷痕ないでしょうに
それで妄想まだやめてないでしょ
本人が死ななくちゃいけないんだけど
死なないでしょ 別に誰も刺してないんだから
そこで怯えて死んだんではないかと思って倒れちゃって
恐怖感で 起こしていて
また目が覚めますからね
目が覚めたらまた死ななかった
だからもう一度やられそうと
また同じことになる これで繰り返すんですよ
だから実際の包丁に刺される苦しみっていうのは
本当にそんなちょっとどうったことはない
病院に行ったらもう治ります
早く行ったら 妄想の攻撃だったらもう切りがない
面白いことは妄想は本物じゃないんですけど
苦しみが本物っていうことなんです
それどうしようもないんですよ
だから我々肉体の痛みも感じるのは心で感じているんだからね
肉体には痛みないんだからね
肉体はただの物質でしょ？感覚ないんです
感覚っていうのは心の働きなんです
だから心は苦しみ感じる機械なんですよ
心を自分で妄想しちゃうと
いくらでも苦しみ感じるんです
ですから この餓鬼道っていうのは
そういうそれよりもひどい世界で
このサンプルで人間も餓鬼道を作ることはできますけど
あんなのは序の口で それはそんな苦しいと思う必要ないんです
あまりにも精神的にいかれちゃって自殺したってもどうってことないんですよ
あんなのはそんなに悲しいと思うほどの苦しみじゃないんです
そんなもんじゃないんですよ
餓鬼道に生まれたら 業で生まれますからね
生まれたらその次元の中で生活するしか
もうどうしようもないんだから
どうしようもない なんで人間妄想するのかと思う
やめなさいと言っているんですけど
やめないんだからね やめなさいという人に偉そうなこと説教するんだからね
なんでこの精神的にね
もうものすごくダメになっている人に説教されなくちゃあかんですかね
何の精神的な問題ない人が
アドバイス聞かなくちゃあかん？それは親切じゃない
その場合は 何を知っていてね
精神的な健康の人にあれこれと言うんですかね
こちらの話聞かなくちゃあかんでしょうに
だからこの自我ですね
この我の強さですね だから助ける
助けられる あの あれも本人が落とすんですよ
だから溺れていて 何か救命
何と言いますか 輪っか
浮き輪がありますけど
浮き輪はそんなものは嫌やと
捨てるんだから こういう浮き輪の糸を持ってますけどね
もうロープを どうしようもないでしょう
あるいは浮き輪投げたら何するの？私はもう大変でしょうに
もう泳げないし 今溺れてるし
その これ掴める？掴まれるんでしょうかねという
あんなあれこれって言っちゃうと
どうすればいいんですかね
だからまあそんなもんで
別に人は溺れてる時はそんなことしませんだけど
妄想の人はそういうことをしますね
精神的に病気になる人は
まずアドバイスを否定する
否定するんだったら最初から聞くなよっていうことで
来るなよと 大体精神的な病気の人はよくよくカウンセラーのところに行くのは自慢するために行くんですよ
カウンセラーにも教えてあげますよと
私の偉大なる能力をと
治らないんです カウンセラーは仕事だからね
親切に聞いてあげますけどね
私のところに来たらもうダメです
仕事じゃないんだからね
お金ももらえませんからね
1対1でやらなくちゃいけないんです
親切に聞いてあげる義務がないんです
そういうことで まあ妄想するっていうこと
大変なことでね やっぱり餓鬼道に落ちたら
そういう人は当然餓鬼道に落ちますしね
どうしようもないし ものすごいひどいんで状況は
だからこのサンユッタ・ニカーヤね
たくさんありますよ 餓鬼道の話が
実際に見たものはね ラッカナソンジャとかね
ワリボウトソンジャとかね
たくさんでもないんですけど
一部だけ選んでね 仏教に興味あるガキがいっぱいいますからね
仏教に興味あるポイントだけ取って
他全部捨てちゃって 記録して
それはもうものすごいケースで大胆なケースだけです
こちらの出てきたガキにも
こうやってもう 6000個ぐらいのよくよく数えたもんですね
そういうこの数字がそんなに気にしなくてもいいんです
たくさんって意味なんですね
たくさんと言うために1万個と言えばいいんですけど
そこまでは言わないで
適当に で 体の長さもかなりの長さこちら書いてますけど
もう何十キロぐらいとかね
だから何十キロぐらいでかい体っていうのも
これソンジャンにまあ普通人間の目だったら見えませんしね
まあ超能力では見えますけど
だからまあ一般的に人間は驚く
それぐらい高い体かなという
この驚いてびっくりしたしたければ
それ十分ですよ ですから
この いわゆるイメージで
このこの絵を描けるように書いてるんですよ
餓鬼道の絵とか 地獄の絵とかね
で 書いてほしいんですね
だから人間にイメージできるような範囲でもう書くんで
本当は書けません イメージもできません
だからそういう教育的なカラクリなんですね
6000個のハンマーが落ちると
体も一応燃えているし
体もまあまあ長いんですけど
例えばまあ10キロぐらい 10
キロメートルぐらい背が高いんだったら
6000個はそんなに大きい問題ではないんです
で  1つハンマーがドーンと落ちて
体通してすっごく痛みを感じさせながら
キャーキャーって泣いてる間で
これずっと下まで落ちるんですね
体の中から で それで次のハンマーも落ちてます
次のハンマーも落ちてます
次のハンマーも落ちてますから
ハンマー落ちて体壊す
下行くんですけど 上はまた修復しているんです
また新しいハンマーが落ちて
また新しい痛みが出てくるんですね
それでハンマーが下へ行くと下が痛いんですけど
上はまだ修復しておりますからね
で 良かったと思うと また次のハンマーが落ちてますから
だからずっと痛みが流れるという意味なんですね
だからでっかい体で その場合
体がでっか 高い方が苦しみの方が大きいんですよ
もう本当は身体の苦しみっていうのは体の大きさで決めるものじゃない
同じなんです だと思いますけど
わかりません それはやっぱりまあ
そういうことでしょうね
まあだからそのガキがずっと体が潰れている
潰れている痛みを感じて
頭の上から ずっと下まで体が潰れて壊れていって
またまた潰れて壊れて
またまたと絶えず 何百万年も何千万年もその苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけない
業が消えるまで それでお釈迦様のところでこの笑えた理由は言ったんです
なんでお釈迦様のところで言うかというと
この証人が必要なんですね
そう言われたお釈迦様も
実は私もそのガキを見たことがあるんだということになるんです
その人がどんな罪を犯したかというと
この昔話とか物語なんですけど
あるこの足が 身体障害者がいてね
あの 普通生活できないんですけど
手だけは五分ですね 一本の
それでこの歩けないんだから
誰かに運んでもらって
大きな木の下に朝置いておくんです
置いただ動かないんで
もう足はないしね そのままいるんです
いるとまあいろいろな人々が来て
その人のところに小石持っていくんです
小石持っていって 何か作ってくださいと
何を作るかって この人は小石をこの打つんです
あの葉っぱに どれほど上手かというと
じゃあ象 象を作ってくれと言ったら
一枚の葉っぱに穴を開けるんで
象の形に 鳥を作ってと言ったら
はい 鳥ですかねとか 日本でなんとか芸術ありますね
あのハサミで ん？切り絵
なんか言ったらもうなんかガチャガチャ喋りながらそれは作っちゃうでしょうね
すごい技術でしょ だからもうものすごいそんな風な芸人なんですね
で それでまあ食べ物もらったりして
この国の王様がその王様の御苑だからね
王様の宮に行ったら 下見たら何か動物の形が映ってるんですね
あの葉っぱからね どういうことです？なんでこんな風になるんでしょう
この木はって言ったら
まあ話を聞いて こういう人から
で まあそういう王様も本当に政治家っていうのはいいことを考えるんだから,はっ
この人の能力を買う方法あるんだと
この王様にこのアドバイザーが一人いたんで
バラモン人が 何かこれはあんたどう思いますか？というと
この人喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ
もうキリがない 王様ってどうですか？いや
それはダメです これはやった方がいいです
それで早く話はね サッと終わってほしいんですね
王様忙しいんだからね
これがもうキリがなく喋る
それで全部仕事はそれで停止
この人喋り出しちゃうと
これ嫌で嫌で でもクビにすることもできないし
このバラモンたちが自分の方がアドバイザーたちだから
すごい力あるんだぞと思ってるんだからね
クビにしちゃうと王様もやっぱりまずいんです
王様が腹の中ではね こいつはなんとかしたいと思っている
一般人だったらもう何とかしますけどね
ただ王様が考えたのは
この人なんかすごいいたずら好きな王様なんですね
なんとかできないんでしょうかと
王様は自分で考えた方法がね
この人はちゃんと狙って撃てるんだから
あいつにこの口 口開けたら閉めませんだからね
喋ってる間でなんか撃っちゃえばどうでしょうか
なんかね 口の中に 王様があの人を呼んでね
あのあんたね 私のところへすっごくちょこっとでも喋り出しちゃうと止めない人がいるんだよと
だからあいつの口にあなたね
このヤギの糞を撃てますかと
ヤギの糞っていうのはすごい形が小さくて丸いでしょう
また硬いんです すごい小さいんです
形は全部石よりは同じ形なんです
だから動物の形をする人ねだった
そんなのは何のこともないんだと
ある一箇所に嘘だけだからね
ああそうか よかったと
連れて行ったんです それで王様は全部用意するんです
で あなたもうね 障害者でしょうし
乞食でしょうしね 宮殿にドーンと持っていく
それはバレますからね
だから王様の玉座のところ後ろにちゃんとカーテンがあります
あんたそのカーテンの後ろにいなさいと言って
大量にお腹いっぱいになるぐらいのヤギの糞をね
用意して カーテンにちょっとした穴を開けておいたんです
でこのバラモン人が来てね
王様も玉座に座っていて
1日の用事やっていると
なんとかに過ぎて このバラモン人にあんたどう思いますかと聞いたら
それは王様あれではあかんではないか
こういうことでこういうことでしゃべり出しちゃったんだ
しゃべり出したら このこの人が口を開けるたびに 1個1個1個嘘です
でもしゃべること精一杯で
素早く飲み込んで またしゃべる
しゃべる しゃべると 王様がその分終わったら私に知らせてくださいと
言ったら 王様は別に話を聞いてて
それでカーテンがなんか揺すったんですね
カーテンが揺すったらもう終わったという話ですから
カーテンが揺すったのを見たら
いきなり先生 下毒 下剤飲んだ方がいいんですよ
先生は で どういうことですか
だってこの釜いっぱいヤギの糞を食べたんだからね
これ良くないんだよ 体には
すぐ家に帰って下剤飲んでくださいと
で その時はこの 王様はそんなことをしていいのかということも出てきますからね
いたずらでて 私はね いたずらしたわけじゃないんだと
あなたは戒めませんだからね
人間っていうのはしゃべる力が良くないんだと
用があったら用だけ単刀直入にしゃべって話を済むもんだよと
なんでそれぐらいのこと知りませんだからね
覚えて教えてあげましたよと
言うとバラモン人のプライドはすごく高いし
みんなの前で王様は堂々とね
もう行ったんだから それから王様が質問されても口を開けてしゃべることはできなかったと
で 黙っているだけ黙っているんだと
そこで王様がもう 君のせいで私はものすごい楽になりましたと
もう国の仕事は今は問題なくできますよと
だからまあ大した仕事をしてくれたんですね
国のために というわけで
彼にはものすごい財産をあげて
ものすごい家を作ってあげて
お城みたいなものを作ってあげて
そこでも遊んでもらったんです
一回だけの仕事をでも一生贅沢に
それで ある人が これ見たら
この障害者がね 人が運んでいかないと歩けもないね
何もできない しかし たった一つの技術のせいで
今は大金持ちでね すごい贅沢しているんだと
あの技術学んだ方がいいんじゃないかなと思ったんです
そこでこの行ったんです
で 先生 私にもこの打ち方を教えてくださいと
ああ ごめんね それはと
断る 君にはね 教えることできませんと
で 門前払いする 言うてもいけない
私は先生に気に入られるようにしますからと
言って一生懸命お世話する
自分もカーストもありますからね
この障害者のカーストはないんですよ
王様から特別扱いされただけで
カースト制度はバラモン人のものだから
それは変えられませんから
王様にも だからかなり差別されていたでしょうね
金持ちであってもね この人は自分のカーストは上なのに
そんなことは気にしないで
自分の目的に達するために一生懸命その人のお世話をする
お世話しながらもう 奴隷みたいにお世話しますからね
まあどうしようもなくなります
その時は教えてください
教えて 断ります 断ります
だけではいかないんだからね
教えることになったんです
それで終わりましたし
技術はね 学んで 終わったらもう終わりますわよと
あなたの勉強は で 卒業させたんで出て行ってくださいと
もう終わりましたからね
これからは何とか仕事をすればいいでしょうし
はい わかりましたと では私は外に行って
自分がどれくらい能力あるのか試しますと
そしたら先生はあんた何するつもり？だからこの狙い撃ちと力強さの両方ですからね
ピッチャーと同じですね
ただしっかり投げただけでは打たれますからね
強さも必要なんです そうするとストライクだと分かっても打てないんです
バット振る前にもう球が行って終わってますからね
だからまあこの人は健常者だからね
体力あるんだからね 先生は
狙い撃ちはできますけどね
強さはあまりないんですね
ですから 先生よりは腕がいいんです
試してみますと ただどうしますか？と言ったら
牛か人とか誰かね 撃って殺してみますと
現代人と同じ この技術は武器開発にどのように使えるのかと考えることとまるっきり同じなんです
なんとか新しい技術開発では
これはもう武器軍隊にどう使えるのか
まずそれを考えるんです
レーザーの光線を発見した途端
これはもう戦争に使える
電波技術 これをどうやって
で 計算機の技術を開発していくと
これはどうやって精密に計算して人を殺せるのかと
だから現代人と比べたら
あえて悪い人間じゃないんで
ごく普通な人間なんですね
だから現代の価値観から見れば立派な人間なんです
頭が正しいとアホじゃないんだと
ということで この人考えたのはもう石
小さな石 one コロで
人か牛か誰か殺していますと
殺せるのかと それで先生はね
牛一頭殺したらサタン弾道っていうのはわかりませんだけど
百罰は百ですという意味なんですね
人を殺したら罰は千だと
これはあまりわかりません
百と千は何なのかと 金
金かというとね あれ何でしたっけ
百両千両という意味かもしれませんだけど
罰金はね それで終わりませんと
君の子供まで子孫まで
この格が下すんだからね
それから苦しまなくちゃいけないんだよと
ですから自己破壊するなよと
そういうことなく 他の何かで試してくださいと
それはよくわかりましたと
言ったのはそうやって持ち主のない
訴える親も誰もない そういう何とかで試してみてくださいと
もう簡単に人を殺さないで言った方が良かったのにね
それでこの人は言って
牛なんか見たらもうどうしても石を投げたいんですよ
だからこの牛誰の？と聞くんだけど
何々さん あ そう じゃあやめます
人間見たら殺したいんだけど
あんたどこの人？誰の人？って聞くんです
こじき見たってこじきにも親戚がいますからね
まあ危ないんです なかなか殺せなかったんです
それでスネットという名前の独覚仏陀がいたんです
独覚仏陀っていうのはお釈迦様と同じ仏陀なんですけど
説法は全くしない 喋れません
祝福一つだけ 幸福でありますように
それで終わり それ以上は喋れません
仏陀は仏陀なんです だから独覚というんです
一人だけ仏陀で  初めてこういう長い講義を聞けるんですけれども
トイレ休憩とか  え？ トイレ休憩
どうぞどうぞ  一人で全体でやめるということはない
ない 迷惑です 聞きたければどうぞ
あった方がいいと思いますけどね
皆さん随分よく性格できているんだから
また揃うのは大変です
で すぐ終わります それも思い出してくれて
本当に良かったんです
すごく早く終わります
それで独覚仏陀がいて
独覚仏陀見たら この人には母親も誰もない
もう誰も訴えないんだろうと思ってね
自分にはどれほど精密に撃てるのかといって試しちゃったんです
で ブッダが托鉢に出ているんですよ
それすると右で右の耳を当てて石を一つ投げたんです
どれほど強烈に投げたというと
サッと弾が入ったような感じで
サッと左耳から出たったんです
それでそのまま 神通力ありましたから
そのまま空へ飛んで 自分住んでるところに行って亡くなったんです
それで人々は知ったんです
仙人が亡くなられたと
それでこの人はもうみんなにもう自分がもう腕がいいということは発表することでしたから
宣伝ですね みんな大勢集めて
ブッダのために泣いたりするとね
あんた知ってますか？誰がそれやったのかとね
私はこういうちっちゃな技術でこれぐらい能力ありますよと
見るです 見えるでしょうと
言うと もう最悪でね 人間がもう何の事したんでしょうかという
この人をぶん殴っちゃって殺しちゃったんです
それで阿鼻地獄に落ちちゃったんですよ
で そこで地獄でものすごい長い時間苦しんでいてね
阿鼻地獄は １こね  １こですね
長い で苦しんでいて それから餓鬼道に落ちて
あの苦しみを苦しんでいるんだということなんですね
で そういうわけで 性格悪い人には技術があると全部なくなりますよと
周りの迷惑よりも その本人に自分の幸福が全部破壊されてしまいますよということで
こちらでお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
何より先に良い人間になりなさいよと
勉強は後ですよと  2番目です
技術も 2番目です 一生自分に必要なのは良い人間であること
良い人間が何を学んだっても
人類のためにそれを使うし
自分のためにもそれを使うし
良い人間が文章を書けるならば
立派な文章を書いて出す
ある人がいて 前の人なんですけど
かなり文章は書けます
すごい苦労しますけどね
迫力ある文章書けます
そこでまああんた私にちょこっと協力してくれないか
私の文章 もう自分なりに好き勝手に書き換えた方がいいんじゃないかと
私に時間ない 何の仕事もやってないんです
で 私は直すとは頼んでないんです
私は初めからこの人は恐ろしいと
もう仏教を学びましたけど
仏教を学ぶべき人ではないんだと
教えてはいけないんだという
ずっと痛みがあったんです
あったんだけど どうしようもないんだからね
来て座っちゃうとね まああんた出て行けということできないしね
まあかなりダメージ与えたんですけど
で すぐ能力あるんですけど
断るという やっぱり人の役に立つことはしないというね
性格が悪くなると だから性格いい人だったら絵を描ける人
性格いい人だったら やっぱりこの絵を描いてよかって何か役に立つことあるのかと考えちゃいますよ
音楽家も同じことでしょうし
だからどんな能力でも素晴らしいんですよ
歌えるとかね 演奏できるとかね
何でもいいんです それは性格良い人がそこを身についたら
みんなに幸福を与えてくれる
悪い人がそれを身につけちゃうと
もう自分でも自己破壊になってしまいます
他人破壊はもう言うまでもないです
これは 72番目の意味はそういう意味なんです
それで話は終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]